they say that everything we do online
leaves a digital footprint we're in the
world of business all the workflows you
do are expressed as your digital twin
hello my name is jamil spain
developer advocate with the ibm cloud
now when it comes to defining how what
your digital twin is it comes to a
process called
process mining not a process called
process mining but if we want to break
that down
process naturally refers to a business
function a particular workflow that you
actually uh do and the mining
naturally means getting some information
if you've probably typed that in a
search bar i'm sure it'll lead you down
a rabbit hole straight to a lot of
crypto but we're really talking about
something more specific here
and it's all the actions that a business
does they have they work with different
enterprise corporate i t systems whether
it's your saps your oracles
legacy systems or
any kind of crm
erp that's all the acronyms that i have
there but the goal here is that each
system that you use
naturally has
logs that are generated from the actions
that you do inside the these systems
now when i think about process mining
we're going to put this in the context
but let's think for a second what it is
not
and something else that's very popular
that comes to mind i can say has been a
buzzword of of yet that we all know
about is data mining so let's take a
second to draw some distinction
actually between the two so they both
involve
clearly probably make a connection with
getting data but for me data mining
dm means really reading a lot of raw
data from logs and i'm really trying to
make a pattern there so i'm looking for
the patterns
but that's about where it ends from
there i have to make a lot of the
intelligence or analyze patterns or
theories from there about what does it
mean what does all the data mean what is
it really of value does it give me
that's the word i'm looking for the
value that it actually gives me out of
there but when we get to building that
digital twin for a business it's really
about two things
it really involves at the most smallest
perspective it's task mining
and there's really a hierarchy here i
naturally have a process overall
let's say that that process is setting
up an account at a bank or handling a
customer service call or
a supplier ordering from a manufacturer
all right the many different use cases
that come here so that particular
process let's say that it's setting up a
new account you know there's different
tasks that are associated with that we
can actually get information back as we
collectively say each task that's there
let's say this was a three-step process
all right and that collectively equals a
the process of making an account
so step one two and three i wanna get
information back on each of those and
that collectively gives me insight to
what this process kind of means and that
ie is process mining but how does this
magically occur all right let's get a
little more into
how these particular things occur so the
first is it there's three stages that we
want to go through the first is
discovery so i'm going to take actual
inventory on everything that's occurring
if it's my actual systems i want to look
at all the log data from these it
systems
and i also want to look at the other
steps that happen in between
maybe me getting that account data maybe
a form that comes in the email and i may
be kind of pasting that email into
another system to work with it all that
stuff i want to record all the
interaction that happens now there's
actually software that goes on your
desktop that's able to record all these
actions and collectively it gives me all
the connections that are there so when i
think through this i have a system crm
and it's going to generate some log data
and then i have also what happens at my
desktop
and i'm going to do the record to
actually get all those actions that are
occurring
now those collectively i'm going to do
leads me to my second phase
all right which is the monitoring
and in the monitoring phase i'm going to
take all these actions that i have and
my goal here is to really make my
find out how do i digitally represent
this process that i'm actually going
through now this is the actual into
invisibility of what's actually
occurring so a lot of times one of the
benefits of process mining why it is
important is because you actually get to
associate actions to a particular
workflow some of those are happy paths
and some of those can be those ones that
take you out in the left field that you
spend a lot of time doing but the most
important thing is that you get to
actually physically represent this along
with metrics that go along with it to
know
the next step is the optimization
now in this step in this phase rather
i'll have the visibility of having a
self
service dashboard
and it will give me the ability to
oversee this process get particular
metrics that i can really start to
understand how am i performing all right
another great benefit of this is this is
really where you start to bring in can
really take on the early beginnings the
foundations of automation
what they like to call intelligent
automation where i can use many
different types of technology to look at
this process that i have this path and
how can i make each one of those
efficient now if you are coming to this
brand new process mining is your path to
know where to start first
naturally just having a process that you
are going through it may be a little
difficult it will be difficult to know
where to start from this gives you an
entry point
and metrics to know when i am getting
something making it very efficient and
the fact that i have access that i'm
using with
my it systems along with the actual raw
data of every task that everybody is
doing everyone does in this workflow it
really gives me the not only the uh
i have the indian visibility but now i
also have the fact based insights
i no longer get to make assumptions
about
what's occurring how long it takes i
have the raw data to back it up and it
gives me decisions to understand
why we do things a certain way why we're
going to improve it why it should be
function that way to run
so naturally you can do a lot of things
with
see it feels like task mining could work
on your own but having process mining
the overall architecture of what you're
trying to improve along with the
individual tasks that are part of this
along with the systems that you're
interacting with
really gives you something powerful you
can really get started to really improve
your business
most importantly identify weaknesses
and and parts you can improve on
and really have a once you go through
your first experience imagine in an
enterprise
that you're able to or start up you know
either one can work
where you're actually able to model all
the actions you do
maybe from i know a lot of times we have
sales teams so imagine from having a a
opportunity call come in to the time to
closing the deal if i'm able to identify
all those steps that gives me places i
know hey we need to respond back to demo
requests faster or those contact forms
it takes us a long time to actually
respond that data gets lost in a
database does not get to someone fast
enough so again getting these
visibilities i can have a really
composite view
of my whole enterprise or my whole
functions that all my business does and
really be able to start to now that i
have this kind of closed loop that i can
keep reiterating through
now that i have the optimization i can
really go back and discover more
monitor it improve these paths
and then go back and keep viewing the
inputs there to go
now again as i said in closing that this
is really the early starts of getting
into
intelligent automation using many
different technologies for instance if
there was a particular task that's done
on a desktop i could deploy something
like rpa to do that actual task you know
if it's maybe put data into a form for a
legacy system that's something i can get
a bot to actually do for me in that
place
so this is just the beginning of
unraveling the the amazing part of
building your digital twin all your
processes having something technically
that resembles that and also being able
to optimize that and hereby make things
much easier and efficient
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future
please like and subscribe